اتمنى ان تكون دماء ابني حمزه اخر الدماء
من بين الصحفيين واخر الدماء من بين الناس
هنا في قطاع
غزه اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم استشهاد الصحفيين حمزه
الدحدوح نجل الزميل وائل الدحدوح ومصطفى
ثريا في قصف اسرائيلي استهدف سياره كانت
تقل صحفيين غرب خانيونس جنوب قطاع غزه
ليرت فع بذلك عدد الصحفيين الذين استهدفوا
بنيران الاحتلال في القطاع الى 110 منذ
بدايه الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه تجدون
المزيد من اخبار حرب غزه في رابط بالتعليق
الاول بعد الجدل والانتقادات لاخفاء دخوله
المستشفى وزير الدفاع الامريكي يقر
بمسؤوليته بشان ابقاء المساله طي الكتمان
وذلك في ظل تقارير تتحدث عن ان كبار
المسؤولين يتقدمهم الرئيس بايدن لم يكونوا
على علم بانه يعاني مضاعفات صحيه تحول دون
اداء
مهامه ايطاليا تدعو الى تشكيل جيش اوروبي
موحد للعب دور في حفظ السلام ومنع نشوب
الصراعات وزير الخارجيه الايطالي قال اننا
بحاجه الى جيش اوروبي ليكون لدينا سياسه
خارجيه اوروبيه فعاله واذا كنا نريد ان
نصبح حافظين للسلام في
العالم عمليات سحب طائرات بوين سب 137
ماكس تتسع الى سائر انحاء العالم بعد
يومين من حادثه تعرضت لها طائره تابعه
لشركه الاسكا اير لاينز الامريكيه جرا
انفصال احد ابوابها بعد الاقلاع ب 35
دقيقه دون وقوع اصابات الى
اللقاء